[Music]
equity is not
equality equity is replacing equality
city of seattle is so excited about this
it's established something called the
equitable
development division we're now learning
that the person in charge of that
division
is a lunatic boxer trace gallagher has
that story for us tonight hey trace
hi tucker ooh box guard here is a somali
immigrant and social justice advocate
who as you say now works for the city of
seattle and is running as a progressive
candidate for the king county council
but
11 years ago garth here who was then a
young mother of two
threatened to blow up a school bus
filled with kids
court documents viewed by fox news along
with audio recordings show
that in january 2010 garth here was
riding on a school bus and told the
driver quoting
a national security incident was going
on when the driver told her to get off
the bus
she started screaming at the kids about
america's relationship with somalia and
told them quote
you need to calm yourselves down because
i could have a bomb look how loose my
clothes are
when the kids panicked and started
fleeing through the exits
she called them cowards now she blames
it all on mental health issues but
police reports court documents even her
own statements
at the time contradict that she didn't
want mental health care
she wanted to go to jail and yet we
should note several state and county
politicians are now
endorsing her candidacy one state
democrat
said quote she would follow ubox
anywhere
tucker trace gallagher for us tonight
thanks so much
we'll have a school bus full of children
that's equity in a phrase
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else